Vous marchez maintenant sur le même chemin que ces premiers artistes.
Et dans ce lieu surréel et hors du commun,
il est presque possible d'imaginer
entendre le bruit étouffé des bottes en peau sur la terre molle,
ou voir le scintillement d'une torche au prochain tournant.
Quand je suis dans une caverne,
je me demande souvent ce qui a poussé ces hommes à descendre aussi profondément,
à braver des chemins dangereux et étroits pour laisser leur trace.
Dans cette vidéo,
filmée à un demi-kilomètre, ou à un tiers d'un mile, sous terre,
dans la caverne de Cudón en Espagne,
on a trouvé des peintures rouges sur un plafond
dans une section alors inexplorée de la caverne.
Alors que nous rampions à la militaire, le plafond se faisant de plus en plus bas,
nous sommes finalement arrivés au point où le plafond était si bas
que mon mari et photographe du projet, Dylan,
ne pouvait plus régler l'objectif de son appareil photo reflex numérique.
Alors pendant qu'il me filmait,
j'ai continué en suivant la piste de la peinture rouge avec une seule lumière
et un appareil-photo compact que nous gardions pour ce genre d'occasions.
Un demi-kilomètre sous terre.
Sérieusement.
Que venaient-ils faire aussi bas avec une torche ou une lanterne ?
(Rires)
Je veux dire, moi, ça se comprend, non ?
Mais vous savez,
c'est le genre de questions auxquelles j'essaye de répondre par mes recherches.
J'étudie l'un des arts les plus anciens au monde,
créé par ces premiers artistes en Europe,
il y a entre 10 000 et 40 000 ans.
Et je n'étudie pas cet art que parce qu'il est beau,
même si parfois, c'est effectivement beau.
Mais ce qui m'intéresse, c'est le développement de l'esprit moderne,
de l'évolution de la créativité, de l'imagination, de la pensée abstraite,
de ce que ça signifie d'être humain.
Toutes les espèces communiquent d'une façon ou d'une autre,
mais seuls les humains ont développé leur communication à ce point.
Notre désir et notre capacité à partager et à collaborer
ont joué un rôle fondamental dans notre grande évolution.
Notre monde moderne se base sur un réseau global d'échange d'informations,
devenu possible, en grande partie, grâce à notre capacité à communiquer :
particulièrement à l'aide de moyens de communication écrite.
Mais le hic,
c'est qu'en nous penchant sur les accomplissements mentaux
de ceux qui étaient là si longtemps avant nous,
il est facile d'oublier que certaines facultés n'existaient pas encore.
C'est l'une des choses qui me fascinent vraiment
dans l'étude de notre histoire profonde.
Ces gens n'étaient pas assis sur les épaules de géants,
ils étaient les géants.
Et bien qu'un nombre étonnant de grandes inventions
proviennent de cette époque reculée,
je voudrais vous parler aujourd'hui de l'invention de la communication graphique.
Il existe trois principaux types de communication :
orale, gestuelle -- comme le langage des signes --
et graphique.
Par leur nature même, l'oral et le gestuel sont éphémères.
Il faut être près de votre interlocuteur pour que le message soit émis et reçu ;
et après le moment de transmission, il disparaît pour toujours.
La communication graphique, elle, découple cette relation.
Et par son invention, il est devenu possible pour la première fois
de transmettre un message tout en le préservant,
au-delà d'un unique instant dans le temps et l'espace.
L'Europe est l'une des premières endroits
où l'on commence à voir des marques graphiques apparaître régulièrement
dans des cavernes, des abris rocheux, voire quelques sites en plein air.
Mais ce n'était pas l'Europe d'aujourd'hui.
C'était un monde dominé par d'imposantes calottes de glace,
de 3 à 4 kilomètres de hauteur,
avec de vastes plaines et des toundras gelées.
C'était la dernière glaciation.
Au XXe siècle, plus de 350 sites d'art rupestre de la dernière glaciation
ont été trouvés sur tout le continent :
des peintures d'animaux, des formes abstraites, voire parfois des humains,
comme dans ces figures gravées, dans la Grotta dell'Addaura en Sicile.
Tout cela nous fournit une ouverture rare
sur le monde créatif et l'imagination de ces premiers artistes.
Depuis leur découverte,
ce sont les animaux qui ont fait l'objet de la plupart des études,
comme ce cheval noir de Cullalvera en Espagne,
ou cet étrange bison violet de La Pasiega.
Mais pour moi, ce sont les formes abstraites, les « signes géométriques »,
qui m'ont amenée à étudier cet art.
Ce qui est drôle, c'est que dans la plupart des sites,
les signes géométriques sont bien plus nombreux
que les images d'animaux ou d'humains.
Mais quand j'ai commencé cette étude en 2007,
il n'y avait même pas de liste définitive du nombre de formes qu'il y avait ;
il n'y avait pas non plus d'analyse
sur l'apparition de symboles identiques dans le temps et l'espace.
Avant même de pouvoir commencer à étudier ces questions,
mon premier objectif était de constituer une base de données
de tous les signes géométriques de tous les sites d'art rupestre.
Le problème était que, étant pourtant bien documentés dans certains sites,
généralement ceux avec de très jolis animaux,
il y en avait aussi un grand nombre où ça restait très vague --
avec peu de descriptions, de détails.
Certains n'avaient pas été visités depuis un demi-siècle, voire plus.
C'étaient eux que j'ai ciblés pour mon travail de terrain.
Durant deux ans,
mon fidèle mari Dylan et moi avons chacun passé plus de 300 heures sous terre,
à marcher, à ramper et à nous tortiller dans 52 sites
en France, en Espagne, au Portugal et en Sicile.
Et ça en valait vraiment la peine.
Nous avons trouvé des signes géométriques non répertoriés sur 75% de ces sites.
J'ai su que c'était ce niveau d'exactitude dont j'allais avoir besoin
si je voulais commencer à répondre à ces questions plus larges.
Alors venons-en aux réponses.
Excepté une poignée de cas particuliers, il n'existe que 32 signes géométriques.
Seulement 32 signes
sur une période de 30 000 ans et sur l'ensemble du continent européen.
C'est un nombre très faible.
Si c'étaient des gribouillis ou des décorations aléatoires,
on s'attendrait à voir beaucoup plus de variations ;
mais au lieu de ça, on a trouvé les mêmes signes
se répétant à travers l'espace et le temps.
Certains signes commencent fort, avant de perdre toute popularité et disparaître,
alors que d'autres sont inventés plus tard.
Mais 65% de ces signes sont restés en usage durant toute cette période :
des lignes, des rectangles, des triangles, des ovales et des cercles
comme ici, datant de la fin de la dernière glaciation,
sur un site vieux de 10 000 ans, dans les hauteurs des Pyrénées.
Alors que certains signes se retrouvent à des milliers de kilomètres,
d'autres signes sont beaucoup plus restreints dans leur répartition,
certains se limitant à un seul territoire,
comme ici avec ces rectangles divisés
trouvés seulement dans le Nord de l'Espagne,
et certains chercheurs ont spéculé
qu'il s'agissait d'une sorte de signes de famille ou de clan.
Soit dit en passant,
il y a un niveau étonnant de similitude avec le tout premier art rupestre,
trouvé en France et en Espagne jusqu'en Indonésie et en Australie.
Beaucoup de ces mêmes signes apparaissant aux quatre coins du monde,
surtout dans cette tranche de 30 000 à 40 000 ans,
on dirait qu'il devient de plus en plus probable
que cette invention remonte en fait à un point originel commun en Afrique.
Mais je crains que ce sujet soit pour une autre conférence à l'avenir.
Revenons à notre sujet.
Sans aucun doute, ces signes étaient significatifs pour leurs créateurs,
comme ces sculptures en bas-relief vieilles de 25 000 ans
de La Roque de Venasque, en France.
On ne connaît peut-être pas leur sens, mais les gens à l'époque, oui.
La répétition de ces mêmes signes, pendant si longtemps et sur tant de sites
nous indique que ces artistes faisaient des choix intentionnels.
Si nous regardons les formes géométriques,
avec des sens spécifiques, convenus, et culturellement reconnus,
alors on pourrait très bien avoir là
l'un des plus vieux systèmes de communication graphique au monde.
Je ne parle pas encore d'écriture.
Là, il n'y avait pas encore assez de caractères
pour représenter tous les mots de la langue parlée,
un trait inhérent à tout système d'écriture complet.
Et les signes ne se répètent pas assez régulièrement
pour supposer qu'ils constituaient un alphabet.
Cela dit, nous avons quelques exceptions intrigantes,
comme ces signes à La Pasiega en Espagne, communément appelés « L'Inscription »,
avec ses marques symétriques sur la gauche,
peut-être des représentations de mains au milieu,
et ce qui ressemble à un crochet sur la droite.
Les plus anciens systèmes de communication graphique au monde --
les cunéiformes sumériens, les hiéroglyphes égyptiens,
les premiers caractères chinois,
sont tous apparus il y a entre 4 000 et 5 000 ans,
chacun naissant à partir d'un protosystème
fait de marques de comptage et de représentations pictographiques,
où l'image renvoyait au sens.
Du coup, le dessin d'un oiseau aurait vraiment représenté cet animal.
C'est plus tard qu'on commence à voir ces pictogrammmes devenir plus stylisés,
jusqu'à devenir quasi méconnaissables,
et que l'on commence aussi à voir plus de symboles être inventés
pour représenter tous les mots manquants dans la langue,
tels que les pronoms, les adverbes, les adjectifs.
Donc, sachant tout cela,
il semble très improbable que ces signes géométriques
de la dernière glaciation en Europe
étaient réellement des caractères abstraits.
Au contraire, ce qui est beaucoup plus probable,
c'est que ces premiers artistes faisaient aussi des marques de comptage,
peut-être comme cet enchaînement de lignes, à Riparo di Za Minic en Sicile,
et créaient des représentations stylisées
de choses provenant du monde qui les entourait.
Ces signes pouvaient-ils représenter des armes ou des objets domestiques ?
Ou des objets célestes comme les constellations stellaires ?
Ou même des rivières, des montagnes, des arbres -- des éléments du paysage,
comme cette penniforme noire entourée d'étranges signes en forme de cloche
sur le site d'El Castillo en Espagne ?
Le terme « penniforme » signifie « en forme de plume » en latin,
mais est-ce que ceci pourrait en fait représenter une plante ou un arbre ?
Quelques chercheurs ont commencé à poser ces questions
concernant certains signes dans des sites spécifiques,
mais je pense qu'il est temps de revoir cette catégorie comme un tout.
L'ironie dans tout ça, bien sûr,
c'est d'avoir soigneusement rassemblé tous les signes dans une seule catégorie.
J'ai l'impression que la prochaine étape sera de tout démonter à nouveau,
des types d'image différents étant identifiés et séparés.
Comprenez-moi bien :
la création, plus tard, d'un système d'écriture complet
était quelque chose d'impressionnant en soi.
Mais il est important de se rappeler
que les premiers systèmes d'écriture ne sont pas sortis de nulle part.
Et que même il y a 5 000 ans,
les gens bâtissaient déjà sur quelque chose de bien plus ancien,
ses origines remontant à il y a 10 000 ans --
jusqu'aux signes géométriques de la dernière glaciation
en Europe et beaucoup plus loin,
jusqu'à ce moment, tout au fond de notre histoire collective,
où pour la première fois, quelqu'un a eu l'idée de tracer une marque graphique
et a définitivement changé la nature de notre communication.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)